l'état et la communauté d'agglomération
ont signé récemment une convention
d'objectifs pour développer l'économie
sociale et solidaire qui présente un
fort potentiel de création d'emplois et
qui répondent aux objectifs de la
responsabilité sociétale des entreprises
et à la politique de la ville et là vous
avez décroché c'est pas grave parce
qu'on va vous expliquer tout tout de
suite vous allez voir c'est pourquoi
tout ça en prime une preuve
l'économie sociale et solidaire c'est un
ensemble assez multiforme d'entreprises
parmi ces entreprises on retrouve des
associations qui ont une activité
économique on retrouve également des
mutuelles
on retrouve des coopératives on retrouve
également des entreprises commerciales
mais qui adhèrent aux valeurs de
l'économie sociale et solidaire alors
ces valeurs c'est essentiellement le
principe de la gouvernance démocratique
de la non lucrativité ce qui signifie
que les bénéfices soient investis
majoritairement dans l'entreprise la
communauté d'agglomération
elle s'implique pleinement dans le cadre
du mois de l'économie sociale et
solidaire dont convoi de beauté novembre
donc ce qu'elle souhaite faire c'est
déjà faire connaître ce secteur de
l'activité alors faire connaître son
caractère multiforme à savoir que
l'économie sociale et solidaire je n'ai
dit tout à l'heure c'est des acteurs qui
sont très différents les uns des autres
puisque ont à la fois des mutuelles
comme la la mgen on a également des
établissements bancaires par exemple
comme la banque populaire val de france
et puis on a également des entreprises
d'insertion comme envie comme un cerf
frau ou nouvelle attitude qui sont
implantées sur le territoire ou qui
interviennent très largement sur sur le
territoire à saint quentin en yvelines
on a à peu près 3 130 entreprises qui
sont recensés comme étant acteurs de
l'économie sociale et solidaire qui
représente près de 4000 emplois et donc
c'est 4,7 pour cent 2 total à près de
100 us emploie cinq ans est en éveil
pour 78 des actifs
donc l'économie sociale et solidaire
j'allais dire hâte de venir à sa propre
origine il ya de vraies perspectives et
puis de vraies perspectives également à
travailler avec les grands groupes
présents sur le territoire
un exemple peut être alors go direction
l'association envie qu'on prenait
entreprises nouvelles vers l'insertion
par l'économique qui propose de
l'électroménager rénové garantie et où
les salariés sont sous contrats
spécifiques d'insertion pour sortir de
la spirale du chômage alors envie vêtu
ce qu'on appelle une phase donc une
entreprise solide dans la mesure où
selon lui vocation première
c'est de travailler la version dans
l'insertion professionnelle
on embauche des gens qui sont contre
elle doit déterminer d'insertion pour
pouvoir effectivement travailler avec
eux sur un projet professionnel et les
remettent affectivement sur la vois mal
un travail plus pérenne c'est lé
développement durable dans la mesure où
on récupère un certain nombre de
produits qui sont plus âgées un savant
distributeur vient écosystèmes puisqu'on
atteindrait quelques systèmes un titre
je vous rends devront récupérer des
points est certain de co2 par jour voilà
contrepartie de prêts canal 2 % soit
loire en valais est donc effectivement
fait une ponction sur l'a25 entre olivia
qui aurait terminé à la benne en d1
ici
propose à des clients des produits qui
sont peu onéreux
dont on sait alain public site que l'on
a cédé effectivement des ménages et des
gens à faible revenu maintenant tout va
devenir en absolu
le magasin happy team on est à moins de
moitié
moitié prix sur des produits qui sont un
vrai lové nettoyer garantie 1an joueurs
de l'appartement pour la décide de
renouveler le produit y est complètement
démonté complètement nettoyé au karcher
désaffectée à réparer changer des pièces
d'usure des charbons de demain des
moteurs comme l'ex-roi il est remonté
tester et mis en vente sur une surface
de vente qui va peu près de 100 mètres
carrés
et l'actuel en tout ça et bien c'est
l'opération nationale du mois de
l'économie sociale et solidaire qui
porte cette année sur la thématique de
l'emploi pour l'occasion la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et ses
partenaires organisent au mois de
novembre des rencontres et ateliers
ouverts au plus grand nombre
présentation avec ighrem alors y est une
association d'éducation développement
durable
mois de l'économie sociale et solidaire
c'est un mois dans lequel on valorise en
fait justement l'économie sociale et
solidaire travers différents événements
type conférences ateliers rencontres
événement festif tout au long du mois de
9 ans d'un côté une graine coordonne le
mois sur le département c'est à dire que
nous avons recensé en fait toutes les
événements toutes les manifestations qui
sont organisées sur le département des
yvelines pendant un mois nous vendre et
de l'autre côté nous organisons trois
événements
donc en association avec différents
acteurs tels que la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin vous
donc à 50 ans new line il y a
un peu moins d'une dizaine d'événements
qui sont organisés et notamment un
atelier rencontre sur la thématique des
ressources humaines qui aura lieu à la
maison de l'environnement de manigat
mots à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin nuit nous
organisons la journée des acteurs de
l'ess et donc il y aura un village
vivent autrement donc un village qui
sera répartie en différents îlots
thématiques consommer autrement se
soigner autrement se loger autrement
dans lequel nous invitons les acteurs de
la cs du territoire il y aura également
une conférence l'après midi et la
journée se clôturera de façon festive
par une disco soupe en disco soupe c'est
un
événement pendant lequel à partir de
fruits et légumes destinés aux revues ou
qui sont destinés à être jetés en fait
on fait des soupes ou des salades en
tout en musique donc c'est collaboratif
avec un épluche-légumes on fait la
cuisine ensemble avec de la musique un
peu festive disco par exemple ou de la
musique live et ensuite on déguste tout
ça vous avez aussi le 27 novembre
rendez-vous création entreprendre dans
le esse esse à la maison de l'entreprise
est également la clôture du mois de
l'urss sur la communauté d'agglomération
qui aura lieu le 28 novembre on pouvait
retrouver
toutes ces événements sur les sites
internet
et voilà pour la responsabilité
sociétale des entreprises et maintenant
nos actuels
un nouveau volet de travaux s'ouvrent
début novembre à la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines pour une durée de
sept mois les stations de taxis géré par
la communauté d'agglomération sera
recréé des tasses et avenue de la gare
une voie de livraison sera aménagé sur
l'espace libéré ainsi que deux espaces
de stationnement pour les deux roues ces
travaux impacteront directement la
circulation avenue de la gare
stationnement est interdit depuis le 4
novembre depuis le 26 octobre dernier
les particuliers peuvent profiter d'une
large part du parc de la mgen à la
verrière idéal pour des promenades en
famille ses 17 hectares essentiellement
boisé ont en effet été ouvert à la
population sont gérées par la communauté
d'agglomération de 50 en une
www.kia.ca qui point fr vous connaissiez
cette adresse et celle du site internet
du kiosque qui vient non seulement de
faire peau neuve mais qui vous proposons
plus désormais billetterie en ligne afin
d'acheter vos places de spectacle pour
la plupart des propositions artistiques
qui vous sont faites
saint-quentin-en-yvelines clic clic clic
ou gras
un dossier que vous pouvez retrouver
dans le petit contingent mois de
novembre ainsi qu'un portrait du
rugbyman eddine ben arous et en afrique
sur l'ouverture d'une salle d' escalade
à montigny à très bientôt